[Music]
hey everyone I'm Benjamin Baxter
developer advocate for Android TV today
we're gonna talk about building a great
Android TV app so before we dig in the
details let's talk about the ecosystem
now we continue to see two times you're
over your growth we're investing more in
Smart TVs set-top boxes pay TV operators
the ecosystems been pretty strong but
they're all developers let's get into
how can you make a good TV app so before
we talk about what the innards of your
app bar we'll just think about what is
the TV why is it so important now we
have entire living rooms or other rooms
dedicated in a focused around a TV it's
it's a pretty key point for users it's
the focus of an entire room just think
about that for a second so your app
matters the content really matters so if
we try to think about what is the
foundation for an app the biggest piece
is your content that's your value prop
to your user if we add on to that
usability how do you make your app
easier for users to use you know you
have great content how can they discover
more of your content inside your app and
if you want to get that little cherry on
top think about the experience how can
you layer in all these extra things to
build a sweet experience for users no
matter where they are on your app well
dive into each of these concepts and
I'll call them out later on but the key
takeaway is they come for your content
but they stay for your app so what I
want to talk about how do you build a
great TV app there's really three things
to think about playing because content
is important discovering making sure
they can see other content in your app
easily and distributing making your
content easy to find should be as easy
as making your app easy to find so let's
talk about the player playback can make
or break an app let's take a look at
this review feel free to read
so the key takeaway for me is that it
constantly stalls this app is completely
frustrating they ended up with just a
one-star review just because their
player and and reviews matter there's
whole other talks about Google Play and
how to improve your reviews but the
player was the key point here as to why
their app was not as good as it could be
so it's very clear to users that the
playback is important they don't want to
have stutters installs they want to be
able to watch the content and even in
that review they talked about
commercials and ads and they were okay
with it they just didn't like that they
stalled so even showing things that may
be annoying such as commercials as long
as they play fine users are okay with it
so the player we have many options to
build a good player you know media
player is a great tool comes out of the
box in the framework you give it a data
source it's able to chug along on play
and you can build a great experience
with media player if you have more
advanced things you want to do exoplayer
is another great tool we've worked
really hard to make it highly custom
like custom mobile there's a bunch of
extensions if you're using Leanback
there's an extension that hooks into the
Leanback transport controller if you're
doing ads there's a whole bunch of ads
ditching support but let's talk more
about ads ads are important you know
your apps going to make money from
showing ads so in a sense ads are just
as important as the content shown and
displayed to the user so focus on ads
make sure that ads stitching works
whether you should do a server-side or
client-side these are real
considerations you should make for your
app so there's many options for players
media player exoplayer build a custom
player but having a player's a good
start but there's things you can layer
in that top part of the pyramid the
experience you know there's things you
can do to build an experience around the
player to make it even better so we
talked about this at i/o this year
playback controls everyone's phone
should be ready here we go
okay Google skip 5 minutes
okay google pause okay google play these
types of transport controls can be
commands through the assistant adding
this extra little feature this little
nice nougat of delight helps build that
experience for your app this all works
with media session so if you implement
media session callback you get all these
features for free and since I talked
about this at i/o and there's been other
talks about media session from other
people I'm gonna just jam through this
fast pay attention here we go
boom beautiful six wonderful methods
pause play stop seek next in previous
but in in reality like that's a lot it's
a lot to think about all these different
cases but if you use exoplayer this can
be done for you so they've made an
extension that manages media session for
you all you have to do is connect the
player to the media session and it all
works for you out of the box make an
immediate session is also pretty simple
and there's tons of documentation and
talks about media session I'm not going
to go too deep into it but you just need
to make sure that you set the media
session to be active set the controller
set anything else need to set set the
current state are you currently playing
you know what position are you in set up
your media session to be what you need
it to be and once you have a media
session and you have an exoplayer
instance connect them so there's an
extension library media session
connector for exoplayer here you just
add in media session as a constructor
parameter to the media session connector
and then you set the player to your
exoplayer instance this media session
connector understands how to set up the
callback all the edge cases around
playing and seeking now you don't want
to go past the end of the video you
don't want to rewind before the video
starts it handles all those edge cases
for you in this example we are saying
set player player in the null you can
set a custom playback for pair there's
other customizations
you can do as well so if you're a music
app and you have a custom playlist and
you want to set a different order for
how the song is go through the queue you
can set a custom queuing mechanism on
the extension that's it
three wonderful lines of code and
assistants already taken care of for you
all the default behavior you expect done
so having the great players great that
was just one example of how to layer in
that experience to make a player even
better we're going to skip ahead to
discovering content so the whole point
of discovering is you want users to stay
in your app and you want them to
discover and watch content faster so
let's look at this review I love the
first sentence they love love love so
many loves this app
so the key takeaway here is it was a
five-star review and they loved all of
the content was they're easy to find
they can do whatever they need to do
inside that app and watch what they want
to watch funny story that's the same app
that got the one-star review so even
though they had a bad player they worked
on discoverability and they're still
able to have good review in the Play
Store so how can we make content
discoverable you know everything kind of
happens in threes and that's like a rule
comedy it's a really good rule in life
in this case discoverability also
happens in threes you can work on in-app
browsing search with the assistant and
the home screen will start with in-app
browsing there's a beautiful library
Leanback if you've done TV development
you're very familiar with it it's a
template in UI system for you to just
plug in data and it works on building
the UI for you so you don't have to
worry about all the focus handling and
all the user input you can just supply
hey here's the content we have and it
will show for you it's not just how to
browse content though Leanback also
works and shows details so there's a
whole bunch of information about content
you have duration content rating the
Rotten Tomatoes score the album artist
and I can keep going on for the rest of
the 30 minutes this talk but I think you
get the point there's tons of
information the cool thing about it is
you can show it using lean back but you
can also show it multiple other places
on the home screen in search and by
showing all this information sooner it
lets users make these micro decisions
much faster and they don't have to go in
and out in and out to figure out what
they want to watch
so make your users lives easier by
showing them all this data sooner let's
look at another example search again we
talked about this at i/o and there's
tons of documentation on this so I'm
going to kind of breeze through some of
these things quickly search is all
supplied with a content provider content
providers are pretty simple
they return a cursor you're able to do
whatever you want
in the background with this content
provider so boom magic content provider
he perform a search and it returns
results if this did a network call maybe
you have a bunch of pojos this was a
database call you're going to have a
cursor and that's fine
the trick for the search provider is
that it needs to return results in that
match the search managers criteria so
search manager is just a strict way of
saying hey this cursor has a bunch of
columns with these names and then the
assistants able to pull in from that
cursor and say oh here's the title
here's the duration and is able to
figure out what contents we're super
simple to do with matrix cursor and
we'll dive into this a little bit closer
you just need to take each of your
results add them as a row into the
matrix cursor and then return their
matrix cursor the matrix cursor is
really just like a mock cursor it's it's
a 2d array essentially under the covers
so if you don't have to go about how do
I store all these in a database with
these column names you can just mock it
out at the very end of your search so
mapping this is where where the hard
work happens you have a matrix cursor
and it takes in a query projection this
query projection is going to have all of
the columns defined that match the
search manager so here we have suggest
column text one typically is the title
of the content an action a data ID the
ideas what's unique to your content
inside the app and then when you go to
convert your content into this row you
just supply an array an array of objects
you know here's the ID here's the name
and they correspond to the order in
which that query projection was so the
ID the title the action etc all the
fields you have you can return back so a
search manager and with searching with
the assistant you don't have to do all
this extra work you can use matrix
cursor to make that return result much
faster homescreen we've talked about the
home screen for the past two iOS so I'm
not going to talk about the old
I'm just gonna briefly cover it and then
we'll talk about some of the new stuff
that's happening the homescreen has
three key parts your app can have a
channel the app can integrate with the
play next row and for video apps you can
have video previews we've seen up to 2x
increase in engagement when apps have
video previews they look wonderful they
can be as simple as a trailer for a
movie or a recap for a TV show but they
take a little bit more work because it
probably requires a content team to make
that content for you I'm not going to
talk about play next or video previews
since we talked about 4 but what's
driving the channels so just to recap
building the channel is just inserted
into a content provider we have a
channel we get a builder we set the type
2 type preview we give it a name a
description a deep link so when they
open up your channel its able to open
into your app and you set an internal
provider ID this is an ID that your app
wants to keep track of and knows about
then you just get a content resolver you
call insert you give it content values
and you're good to go
once you've stored your channel you
parse out a channel ID you do some stuff
maybe you want to keep track of that
channel ID for synchronization and then
you set a logo so channel really
consists of a name a description a deep
link an internal provider ID and a logo
those are really the key pieces of a
channel so what just happened we created
a channel we inserted it and we stored a
logo so we really did two things with
the home screen insert the channel store
the logo so as of Android x100 we have a
new API this API looks very similar
small differences we have a preview
channel helper class
it takes in the context and then it does
a bunch of lookups to get the content
resolver for you so you don't have to do
context a Content resolver to insert it
does all this work for you
it makes a channel so you have your
builder you set the name the description
the app link and the intent provider URL
and you think you should set the type
but this class knows that it is a
preview channel so it already knows the
type of site preview and you don't have
to set the type instead you can set the
logo now all this stuff is contained in
one unit and you can just call the
helper dot publish channel give it the
channel it figures out all of the work
for you and you get the channel ID back
so what it does under the covers it
inserts the channel into the provider
and then it goes to add a logo if the
channel isn't able to be inserted maybe
you have bad data and you're hitting a
1/8 error or something it'll return an
error back to you if it is able to
insert the channel they tries to store
the logo on that channel if the logo
cannot be persisted it
it throws an exception wraps it all up
unwinds adding the channel so that you
don't end up with like half a channel on
the home screen it essentially treats
everything as an atomic unit pretty
convenient
it doesn't just publish channels it does
everything crud does so we've already
talked about publishing the channel you
can read all the channels you can even
get individual channels you're able to
update a channel and you can delete them
and I'm only talking about channels but
all this how so happens for preview
programs and there's also support for
the play next row in this class but
there's two options to do it which one's
better you could say I just want to use
content providers I'm able to fine tune
the performance I can do batch inserts
bulk operations you know I can get lower
level control I don't need an entire
program with all that metadata maybe I
just want the title and duration and now
I can slow down that query projection
and have faster results and it's based
out of the framework you don't have to
do all this extra work to access it you
get it out of the box from the framework
but if you want to use Android X you get
more convenient
you don't have to worry about all the
nuances of a content provider
it's a one-liner for all intensive
purposes and you get all the fun
benefits of having the Android X in your
app so discovering contents great there
are three ways to go about it in your
app searching with the assistant and on
the home screen with channels but how do
you make your app discoverable the third
thing the app store on TV is a bit
different it filters out a bunch of
content it wants to make sure only apps
that are designed for TV will be shown
so when the user opens up the app store
they're only looking at apps that can be
played on TV or can be installed on TV
trying to navigate the Play Store and
make your app stick out can be hard but
there's three simple things you can do
to have your app appear on the Play
Store first thing is to declare features
and as slide says even if you don't use
it
there's a giant asterisk don't start
declaring like bluetooth just for fun or
location just for fun there's two
features that really matter so the first
one is touch screen no you want to
declare that as false it's not required
to have a touchscreen this isn't a phone
this isn't a TV from way back in the day
you know these are Smart TVs you don't
need touch screen support the second
thing is to declare lean back it's true
this tells the Play Store hey this app
is designed and ready to be deployed on
a TV but if you have all of your code in
the single codebase and you're making a
single apk that deploys on both mobile
and TV set lean back to false this still
tells the Play Store hey this apk is
compatible on both mobile and TV the
second thing you should do is try to be
visible in the launcher now if you're a
headless app like a screen saver or a
keyboard just go away for two minutes
and I'll see you then so to make your
app visible on the home screen you need
to supply a banner you can define a
banner in application or you can set it
in your activity the launcher will go in
through the manifest find this resource
and this is what he
uses to show your icon on the launcher
but once the user selects your icon it
needs to launch something so the
launcher fires an intent and you need to
have an activity that accepts this
intent it's called the Leanback launcher
intent really cleverly named does
exactly that so from the launcher it
will trigger off your Leanback
experience so there's three things you
need to have one declared the two
features so your app will be found on
the Play Store to have a banner so your
app shows up on the launcher and three
have a Leanback intent so that your app
launches when the user wants to wants to
enter your app and that's it you're
ready to go on the Play Store
this talk is done all right but in a
sense that's kind of the minimal Viable
Product you're able to have a strong
player you're able to have easy to find
content and you're able to distribute on
the Play Store that that's that's just a
good app you know how do you make it
great to start with this you should look
at your users imagine all of your users
on a spectrum they start from one side
of the spectrum hey I bought a TV
because it's cool you know everyone's
doing it I want to be cool sits in my
closet but I have a TV no the next far
into the spectrum I love watching TV
every week i watch this show this is
great you go a bit further down oh man I
love how to get away with murder
Fila davis is awesome hey maybe I should
watch Suicide Squad she is also in that
then the far extreme you know maybe this
better examples for sports hey I'm
watching the sports ball game here's a
fantasy team here's a Jersey the player
I like and I just want to keep going and
going into it the the side on the on
that side the left is what's called the
Leanback user they're just gonna be
sitting back watching TV
that's all they want to do the side
highlighted this is what you can call
the lean end user they're sitting on
their edge of their seat oh man this is
awesome who are these people in this
show and and they're go
deeper into the content everything we've
talked about up till now having a good
player making your app usable this is
more for the Leanback
the the the right side of the screen but
if we think about it how can we tap into
that lean in user here we have another
living room a very beautiful living room
I wish it was mine but it's not but if
we look closer you'll see a camera
microphone tablet phone and then as you
start to think about it
the TV is the centerpiece of a living
room there are so many devices around
you know you don't have to just do stuff
on TV you can tap into everything around
the living room so I love Android TV
it's like the focal point of everything
that's happening so in concept again
we're going to do this in threes because
threes are great in concept if we want
to tap into these other surfaces what
should we look to do first step is just
controlling media the playback controls
we talked about earlier this is a great
step it's it's going a little bit
farther advanced you're building an
experience around your app maybe for
another option is to have notifications
hey the big games about to start in five
minutes do you want to watch on your TV
second pillar is more about going deeper
into content
who's the casting crew what are the
behind the scenes of this production you
know are there extra sponsored content
that I want to know more about and then
the third pillar is about reducing
friction how do i how do I install your
app okay its installed how do I sign
into your app I want to make a payment
how do i authenticate that payment in a
secure way outside the TV so let's look
at an example you may or may not know it
but everyone here who set up an Android
TV has already done that third step that
frictionless interaction the Android TV
setup actually does this for you during
the flow they say hey do you want to set
up on the phone they give you a strong
UX indicator you're gonna pull out your
phone you get notifications
you say hey yeah this is me this is my
account and the TV takes over from that
information and it was really
frictionless but how did they do that
it's not magic I promise you it's
something you can do today you can use
nearby so the nearby API is been out for
a while but it's really interesting when
you try to use it on TV what you can do
the way it works is you're going to set
up the TV to be the advertiser and then
the phone's gonna come out and try to
discover hey there's the TV you do all
the work you want to do on the phone and
then send it back to the TV nearby is
going to set up an offline peer-to-peer
wireless connection that's encrypted and
you don't have to worry about a lot of
things because you're gonna have this
intimate connection between the phone
and the TV what's dive a little bit
deeper so getting started with this
let's start on the TV side cuz I'm I'm
on Android TV so I'm a bit biased we're
going to start on TV first TV is gonna
start advertising the way you do this is
you set up nearby dot get connections
client nearby is just a nice singleton
helper class from the nearby API that
has all these things to help you get
started you call start advertising
you're going to give it a name a service
ID package name is perfectly fine you're
going to give it a connection lifecycle
callback and you're going to set a
strategy cluster is a really good
strategy if you notice there is also a
p2p point-to-point strategy and you
might be its one TV one phone
point-to-point this sounds great but if
you try to do like multi device setup I
have a TV in my living room one of my
bedroom one of my bathroom all of a
sudden that point the point breaks down
so to make a more robust app you should
think about using cluster you also set
success and failure listeners now these
listeners aren't saying oh I've been
found I've advertised and I found these
listeners say you are able to start
advertising so they're great for
debugging and adding extra information
inside your app the big elephant on this
slide though is the connection lifecycle
callback
this callback talks about how the
devices will talk to each other you know
what what's going to be said is later
but how are they going to say it now is
handled in the connection lifecycle
callback simple three methods
uninitiated there uninitialized results
and disconnected they're pretty
straightforward but what's dive in a
little bit more so in a connections
initialized that means the phone
requested a connection you're going to
prompt for security and do a couple of
things but eventually you're going to
say nearby dot get connections client
accept connection once the new
connections been accepted you'll receive
a result based on that result was that
okay continue on was it rejected maybe
ask for another mother retry but based
on that result you should handle
appropriately and the last one on
disconnected is pretty simple just clean
up any metadata you may have started
collecting the big line here is the
connections client accept connections
and here you pass in a payload callback
this payload callback is going to be
what the devices communicate so you
should have a contract on your phone and
on your TV for what they're gonna say to
each other hey phone we want to do this
hey TV we're going to do this this is
all handled and signed up a little
callback so here a couple tips what
you're going to communicate is very
specific to your app but here are some
tips the payload received and payload
transfer update are the only two methods
you get they're pretty pretty succinct
pretty good methods though on pay low
receive if you want to send an
acknowledgement back hey thanks for
telling us this phone we're going to
send back an acknowledgement so you know
the message had been received it's
really easy you just call send payload
you give it the end point ID that you
received the payload from and some body
in this case it would say ACK or
acknowledge if you want to disconnect
hey I received this payload I want to
disconnect the connection and then and
close this session
you should do that in the transfer
update and the transfer update you
should check to see if it's in progress
or not if you're sending small messages
like ACK and send those those are pretty
fast but if you're sending something big
like a file that could take a while and
you want to check to make sure all the
bytes have been sent once all the bytes
have been sent then you can call
disconnect from endpoint so to summarize
the TV side you're going to advertise
hey I'm a TV you're going to accept the
connection and then you're going to
communicate but on the phone what
happens on the phone side it's going to
look very similar you're going to
discover the TV this time you're going
to request the connection and then
everything after that is going to look
like the slides I just showed you so to
discover the TV you have the nearby
connection client again this time you
call start discovery mind-blown you're
going to give it a service ID now this
time I'm using a constant and there's
there's a reason for the service ID
depending on your app should be either
be the package name or the constant if
you have a package name that's the same
for both your TV app and your mobile app
it's gonna work great but if you have
something like comm that might company
dot Android or calmed up my company dot
Android TV as your to package names
imagine they're kind of on their own
channels and so the nearby connections
library won't be able to find the phone
and the TV so having a service ID that's
used by both sides is a good practice
then you're going to give it a mobile
endpoint discovery callback because I
love really big words and then you're
going to set a strategy this strategy
should be symmetric to what you said on
TV so I urge you to use cluster for this
use case you get listeners again these
listeners are pretty important these say
you are able to start discovery this
does require location permission because
it's going to use bluetooth LE then
default to other ways to find nearby
people so if you get a failure listener
you know maybe it's like Oh permissioned
for location hasn't been enabled so
these are great for debugging and trying
to urge the user down the correct path
so the second part except the connection
really simple you have that mobile
endpoint discovery callback and it has
two methods either found an endpoint or
you lost an endpoint pretty simple if
you find an endpoint go ahead and
request a connection this will trigger
the on connection initialized on the TV
that we saw earlier if you lost an
endpoint maybe the user walked too far
away from the TV and is now no far no
longer nearby or maybe they gave up and
just close the app and said forget it
hopefully it's the first for you not the
second you just clean up whatever
metadata you had collected already
everything after this is identical
you're going to have a connections
lifecycle callback that handles how they
communicate and then you're going to
have a payload callback that says what
are they going to communicate and that's
it that's that's pretty much nearby in a
nutshell but nearby is a cool tool it's
nice to have in your toolbox of kits for
how to add more experience to your TV
app so what's go down payments let's
look at one more example payments I
think is kind of cool it adds this
family-friendly idea you know imagine
you're at work and your kid is at home
and they want to buy the next season of
a TV show you get a push notification
hey are you sure you want to purchase
this TV show and you say ah man my kids
at home buying stuff no oh man my kids
at home yeah they're bored let me use my
fingerprint or face ID or anything in
anything from the phone to authenticate
yourself and all of a sudden you just
enabled a purchase at home from your
office I'd argue that's not nearby
that's there was an API be called far
away right and Shrek might have been as
close to far away as I've seen but I
have not seen that in Android so in this
case nearby is not a good fit it's a
good tool in your toolbox but it's not
necessarily the best fit maybe there's
another good fit let's talk about that
example one more time you get a push
notification
and it says watch on TV or watch here
this is the big game you want to watch
it watching on a small phone yeah
watching on a big TV awesome you could
use nearby to figure out proximity yes
they're close to the TV we should show
the watch on TV up button that's a great
use for nearby receiving the
notification hmm this is a great example
of content immersion as soon as you said
watch on TV the background lit up you're
in this immersive view here's the
schedule for the game here's some
highlights here's the score and then
whenever the user once they can just put
the phone to the side
it's very non intrusive and they can
focus on the game so in a sense this was
kind of kicked off from a notification
and in a way you would say hey that was
more of a push model nearby feels more
like a pulling I'm pulling a
conversation between the two devices
whereas in this case you're more of
pushing that information to the user and
there's a talk about firebase cloud
messaging
after this and I won't step on their
toes too much but we'll just talk about
it for fun what's the worst can happen
you set up a fire based messaging
service you receive a message you know
based on that message you should have
some action here's what to do when you
receive that message if that action
happens to be hey watch this movie or
watch this game start watching and
you're good to go start watching
literally should want launch an activity
this is the Android dev summit I'm
assuming everyone has launched an
activity before but just in case we set
up an intent we give it some extras like
hey here's the video to watch and we
start an activity beautiful the question
really comes down to what happens when
the TV screen is off you know I'm at
home I get a push notification oh man
the games about to start I have to hit
power on my remote I have to tune to the
channel i man this is first of all
problems at its finest but you can solve
those
we have that fragment activity that's
your player when you set up everything
all you have to do is just call set turn
on screen to true now this is a really
cool API on activity this is actually
introduced in om r1 so if you're on API
27 or higher you should do a check hey
turn on screen to true otherwise you can
just add the flag
so to summarize how to build a great TV
app start with your player your content
is king so really focus on the player
whether it's an ad or whether it's
actual content make sure your player is
solid next thing how do you make your
app more usable how do you get that lean
back experience so that users can
quickly find other content to watch the
third pillars distribution is my app set
up to be deployed on the Play Store
correctly once you have all three of
these you end up with happy users and
who doesn't want happy users but if you
want to take your app even further
evaluate your users and layer in these
llenan experiences know how do you do
payments having that push notification
for that media control how do you add
that immersive content here's the
details of the game so thank you
everyone go build great TV apps
[Music]